وصلنا للتو إلى قاعدة عمليات فورد العسكرية الأوكرانية
بالقرب من الحدود البيلاروسية
حيث سيظهرون
لنا التحصينات التي
أقاموها للحماية من
الغزو البري الروسي المحتمل
على بعد أميال قليلة في بيلاروسيا المجاورة
واستعراض القوة الروسية المشؤومة
والقوات البيلاروسية تجري تدريبات قتالية مشتركة
كما فعلوا في وقت سابق من هذا العام
قبل الغزو مباشرة ، هل أنت
قلق بشأن حشد القوات على
الحدود البيلاروسية علينا أن
نشعر بالقلق لأن لدينا أه ليس
جارًا صديقًا ولكن لدينا 2500
كيلومتر حدود غير صديقة بيلاروسيا
روسيا والأراضي المحتلة مؤقتًا ،
علينا أن نكون مستعدين هنا ، قال
وزير الدفاع أوليسكي ريزنيكوف
لشبكة CNN إن أوكرانيا تستعد في حالة
غزو الروس من بيلاروسيا مرة أخرى ، حيث
يقول إنهم بحاجة ماسة إلى مزيد من الأسلحة
المضادة للدبابات وأنظمة دفاع صاروخي أكثر تقدمًا
نحن لا نخاف منهم هذا.  هو
القبطان الذي سيقابلهم لا نتوقع
منهم أن يأتوا إلى هنا ولكن إذا فعلوا ذلك فسنكون كذلك
استعدادًا ، يتدرب هؤلاء الجنود باستمرار على
استعداد في أي لحظة ،
أه هل تعتقد أن الروس
سيحاولون العودة مرة أخرى ، ربما
دعهم يحاولون ذلك
قبل الحرب ، قام بإصلاح
ماكينات الخياطة الآن وهو يقود هذه السرعة التي
يمكنك بها توصيل الرجال إلى الخنادق إذا
تحتاج إلى أه سيكون سريعًا جدًا ، يقول
إنهم بدأوا في بناء هذه الخنادق في
أوائل أبريل لتعزيزها منذ
أن استعدوا للروس الذين
تغلبوا على الدفاعات الأوكرانية في
بداية الحرب ستة أسابيع
وآلاف القتلى جنود على الصعيد الوطني لاحقًا من
هذا  ساعدت الكتيبة في إجبارهم على الخروج من
أي وقت مضى حيث كان هناك وقت كان فيه الأمر
ساحقًا حيث كنت تعتقد أننا لا نستطيع
القيام بذلك ، لا يمكننا محاربتهم
لم أفكر أبدًا أن هذا يقول إنه
لأني أعلم أنه لا توجد طريقة للعودة
لدينا عائلات في المنزل  لدينا أطفال ،
كان يقول إن 2500
سيارة روسية تمر بالفعل على هذا الطريق مباشرة
الآن نحن نسير على نفس الطريق
إلى جسر بالقرب من الحدود داخل
روسيا  نطاق المدفعية
عندما غزا الروس منذ أكثر من تسعة
أشهر ، سافروا في هذا
الطريق مباشرة فوق هذا الجسر ، لكن الجسر الآن
مليء بالمتفجرات
وأراضي المستنقعات التي تم
تجميدها مليئة بالألغام عندما كانت القافلة الأولى
من ما يقدر  جاء 30000 روسي
في شباط (فبراير) الماضي ، ولم يكن الأوكرانيون
مستعدين وكان عددهم يفوق عددهم ستة إلى واحد
الآن مثل الجنود منذ قرن مضى
كانوا يتحصنون في الخنادق في
انتظار كل ما يأتي على الطريق